Tom Hanks and Tom Holland the pair
recently went to buy Oh laughter Hank's
impromptu acting lesson for spider-man
on the UK's grandeur show would you like
more coffee it was really stressful
actually no one actually told me that
that was gonna happen the challenge was
how many different ways could Holland
say the same on coffee coffee please sir
I need some work off with the lights
more coffee coffee coffee please circle
on it need some more coffee when Tom
Hanks you know the legend that he is
asked you to step up you best believe
you better step up what do you like some
more coffee coffee please Helen had an
easier task yesterday with his Spidey
friends lighting up the Empire State
Building then heading to the observation
platform a hundred and two stories up
this is a height I'm not that accustomed
to whenever we do those sequences we
always have a set that's actually only
20 feet off the ground
I get like a bit of a weird kick out of
doing the high stunts I kind of like the
adrenaline rush I mean it's kind of
obvious the event called attention to a
non-profit the brothers trust started by
Tom and his three brothers saving the
world requires sacrifice
spider-man far from home was shot in
iconic locations across Europe so where
to next have somewhere tropical
somewhere tropical
you know spider-man goes into wine
you